[Music]
you think everyone's stressed here
working then
then going to survive here
people have like
their Source income Source something
business something Farms
so they are enjoying actually
how um how big are the families there
like how many kids do people usually
have
a very big families like we are
enjoying in a close family
like we we can celebrate as well in in
our like Vlog families Lottery lessons
like in my family blood relations family
we have like
uh 45 46 families this is the blood
relations family
uh and same like other people as well
very close relationship
and in the house we have
like a father mother sister's
grandfather
like other family as well joining
so for example when we have kids and no
problem to take care so we have so many
people yeah very difficult
uh so it's not as difficult like to have
a lot of kids because there's so many
people around yeah but here you have no
one to help but they're like strangers
like you could you could get a
babysitter but it's not like you know
them
[Music]
why do you think um the family isn't as
important in England but it's more
important in Nepal like why do you think
that is
I I can hear about my other family they
don't want to come here
no I mean like um
like just observing the culture because
I'd imagine as an Uber driver you hear a
lot of stuff so like why do you think um
family is so important in Nepal but not
here like what do you what's the
difference do you think
yeah I actually I don't know how to
explain
[Music]
yeah you mean my other family is also
they're gonna bring here yeah yeah
I told you like my father
now he's
is
around 67 years old
now
you have our own business
uh you have a daily stops
and he participate
in the social work as well so many
social work organizations
like Finance
organizations he involved
so
he always like a trouble
uh going in one organization
they are doing work and to communicate
with other people as well but when he
come here
and no one only me my family we are also
always busy
so my father don't have other people to
talk
he's a bit lonelier here like he feel
like lonely you know
no so I mean like what do you think like
not not your family but like the culture
you know how the culture here is very
much like more individuals like people
don't have a lot of kids
and it's like smaller families and
apartments like you don't you don't see
them you said there was like 75 people
um you don't really see that like what
like what do you think causes it here to
be different than their
yeah actually I didn't know
I didn't look different but
Nepal is like a different type so it's a
different type of yeah different type
enjoy
they are different
but you said they're happier yeah
I'm here only because
uh
yeah I want to give my child
are the women different in um and the
men different in Nepal like um are they
the more into like gender roles you know
here actually people don't have time
well they have time
so it looks like
if people have time obviously they have
time to talk
and this reflect like politeness yeah no
people don't have time
and looks like a rude or selfishness you
know actually not but it looks uh
reflected like that
that's really interesting so people are
so busy yeah so busy that they don't
like talk to each other they don't
they're a bit more rude but it's it's
just because they're so busy yeah
because of bees yeah
when you're driving
and you hear people have conversations
what do you hear people like talk about
the most
not they're talking just uh actually
they are not talking frequently with me
only little bit
uh only they're talking themselves like
some people talking the business talk
sometimes some people they are family
talk
I was just curious if like because how
how many hours do you do this a day
10 hours so it's like you have people in
and out of your car for 10 hours a day
yeah so I was just wondering if there's
like patterns that you see of like the
same conversations or they're always
different that you hear people talking
about
[Music]
the answer for that
people talking themselves I don't know
do you think you'll go back to Nepal
Milan
the plan is like in my
Fair
obviously I need to give time to them as
well
so maybe after 10 years
now now like every two years seven years
I'm going
but after 10 years my plan is like
I had spent time off here and half in
the park
actually I prefer to live in Nepal
do you prefer there all my family is
so
after 10 years
yeah
Maybe
sometimes oh dear sometimes here
how many kids do you have
two two sons
all right
and another one eight years ago
does it matter to you if they um
like date or marry someone from here or
would you want them to date or marry
someone from Paul
does it matter to you if they date
someone from like here or if they would
rather like date or marry someone from
like Nepal
does that matter to you or no
I'm married yeah
like me no no you're you're kids when
they get bigger so when they grow up
okay could they marry someone from here
do you care or does it not matter to you
[Music]
obviously I can't
control and I can't push them when they
are
25s yeah I can't control them
but my advice for them to marry from
like a Nepalese girl
the reason is
in our culture
uh in our culture have like a divorce
percentage is very low
very very low
we fight as well like not physical fight
like we have argue as well
but we compromise and let uh
that problems being solved
then again we are happy
but I feel like here
if the husband and wife
have like
issue
and then they don't think
it just makes sense they just they just
they get divorced too easy here so many
so many
times so many times I saw and I feel
very sadness like
one father
come with sun
and that sun
drop to the ex-wife house
and I feel like
that sun
went happy when the father and mother
I don't know
he want father and he want mother as
well but father is in our own house
mother is in another house
[Music]
did the um
you know culture like we compromise our
culture is like that
um you make it work no matter what
we're here they they get divorced pretty
easy yeah and they they think uh for
that very normal
that's normal here but it's not normal
in Nepal yeah it is not like normally
Nepal
do you think um
just say this
is
are the women more different here or are
the men more different here would you
say
the same thing that's the same
that with your friends sorry
woman also
but like
very rude or something bad behavior man
also not because sometimes situation
happens but it's the same yeah not like
particular woman is like bad
back
um I was going to ask you do you um your
friend that got divorced
um was he able to see the kids okay
did your friend get to like see the kids
yeah with the with the mother did she
like did they did he get to see his kids
okay
[Music]
um so you said my mind is not very well
no it's okay you're okay
um so your friend that was married yeah
and then he got divorced he said yeah
uh here here yeah right uh yeah yeah
right yeah so did
he get to see the kids still after
or was it like harder
uh I had no idea about that but only I
see for other people not my like my
friend something but here divorce uh
ratio is very high you know it's very
it's very high very high it's like 50
percent I think
but I just wonder
why other countries
um
get along so much better than hear the
men and the women like why
um when they have less money and
resources it seems like
um or it's like less developed the men
and the women get along better and I
just wonder why
in Nepal usually men
work pretty hard
woman
work very less
woman to take care in the house in the
house to work usually
and the men walk outside doing business
something something like that
and about the money
he asks about the money who earn more
than more men or women
here in Nepal you asked me oh yeah
amen amen right man
[Music]